for
[Music]
long de the Imperial
Army the Imperial
Army
[Music]
I the alance to the flag of the United
States of
[Music]
Amer the Adam
bom
[Music]
we will arrive at Yokohama at 09:30
hours we will arrive at Yokohama at 0930
hours debar priority will be in
accordance with the debarkation
[Music]
schedule general Douglas
MacArthur arrived at atsugi Naval
Aerodrome near
Yokohama on August 30th
1945 as he emerged from his aircraft he
paused at the top of the steps stuck one
hand in his hip Pockets tightened his
Jaws around his corn cob pipe and
surveyed the conquered lands
this pose was repeated several times
from different angles so that all the
Press photographers could get a decent
shot democracy was to be instilled in
the Japanese people as though they had
never heard of
it our problems in the brain inside of
the Japanese head these brains like our
brain can do good things or bad things
all depending on the kind of ideas that
are put
[Music]
inside Kabuki plays featuring loyal
Samurai were banned or heavily
censored as were books and films about
the bombings of Hiroshima and
Nagasaki satirical cartoons of MacArthur
and mention of occupation censorship was
strictly
[Music]
forbidden the commission finds you
guilty as charged and sentences you to
death by hanging Yash himself thanked
the commission for the fairness of his
trial prime minister at the time of the
war in the Pacific General Tojo remarked
during his trial none of those Japanese
would dare act against the emperor's
will
the cross-examination was immediately
cut short and a week later Tojo
dutifully stated that the emperor had
always loved and wanted
peace General Hideki Tojo who assumed
official responsibility for the conduct
of the war and did everything possible
to exonerate his
Emperor MacArthur would later remark to
the US Senate that in terms of modern
civilization the Japan jaanese were like
a 12-year-old
[Music]
boy you are interested in the unknown
the mysterious the
unexplainable that is why you are
here when the war was over bank loan
books had
deteriorated the assets the banks held
were mainly war bond
and Loans to destroyed
Industries as such the whole banking
sector was virtually
bankrupt this problem was easily solved
by the bank of
Japan all it had to do was buy the
banking sector's bad papers with newly
created
reserves giving them good money for
assets which were often
worthless the first two post-war Central
Bank governors were nominated by the US
occupation iichi Iraqi was appointed the
first postwar governor of the bank of
Japan but soon after taking up this post
he was indicted by war crimes
prosecutors and had to
resign then in
1951 after a general Amnesty on
suspected war criminals filling public
offices he was made ambassador to the
United
States on returning from his post as
Ambassador in
1954 Iraqi was again made governor of
the Central
Bank after the 1951 amnesty for war
criminals much of the Japanese wartime
bureaucracy was returned to their
wartime
positions this included wartime
politicians and most home Ministry
bureaucrats
who had been in charge of the thought
police a number of which moved to the
education
Ministry Japan is the key to the fate of
the Far East once again for the second
time in the march of modern history
those words have urgent
reality in order to avert the kind of
rural unrest that was helping the
Communists in
China the Americans initiated the
redistribution of land from big land
owners to their
tenants the capitalist elite in Japan
known as the zaibatsu were purged as
supporters of a criminal war and
prohibited from further business
activity basically the the fascist uh
policies of the 30s that the the reform
fascist bureaucrats could not Implement
during the war even yes the US
occupation managed to complete like the
Land Reform and these tys of policies
yeah it's a very funny uh Encounter of
um Japanese wartime fascists and uh
American new
[Music]
dealers the diet home of Japan's Senate
and House of
Representatives in Japan fanatic
students and leftist groups rioted for
days on end seeking to block the mutual
defense treaty with
America the Socialist deputies staged a
riot in the diet itself the police in
restoring order also evicted the
[Music]
[Applause]
Socialists the speaker was carried to
the platform and called to order the
session that approved the
treaty in 1957
the former Class A war crime suspect
Kishi nobuk became Prime Minister of
Japan he had been General tojo's
minister of Commerce and Industry during
the
war where his responsibilities had
ranged from Munitions to slave
labor while Hitler's um wartime war
minister War economy Minister was in
Berlin's bandal prison
Al his Japanese wartime colleague was
prime minister of the country although
Kishi became a defender of democracy
after the
war before and during the war he had
described himself as a national
socialist with money from crime
syndicates industrial corporations and
CIA slush funds Kishi built the liberal
Democratic party into a powerful
political machine
in Japan many of the most important
post-war economic and political leaders
came from an elite group of wartime
bureaucrats the very same people who had
pushed Japan into the
war the liberal Democratic party stayed
in power for almost 40
years welcome home in Japanese to these
American
soldiers after a tour of Duty in Korea
they are returning to their base in
Japan where once a short time before
they were stationed as occupation troops
and how do they return how are they
received by the people whose land they
occupi not as overlords not as
antagonists not as men who are
distrusted and feared and resented but
as
[Music]
friends
in Tokyo's Central Choda board the
Ministry of Finance had its
headquarters from here the ministry
controlled most aspects of econ iic life
in
Japan the Ministry of Finance was the
most powerful Ministry and the bank of
Japan had to report to the Ministry of
Finance Ministry of Finance officials
elicited deep and hushed exclamations of
awe and
respect and former Ministry bureaucrats
obtained influential posts as heads of
private and public
institutions but in one area the
ministry did not have actual
control and that was the quantity of
credit creation and its
allocation which was decided by the
Japanese Central Bank the bank of
Japan they told the Ministry of Finance
and the public and the journalists we
run monetary policy through interest
rates and they let the Ministry of
Finance reign in their interest rate
policies but the rule was done through
not interest rates which is the price of
money it was done through the quantity
of
[Music]
money it worked this way it's called
window Guidance the bank of Japan just
told the banks how much they were going
to lend they will have to lend in the
coming quarter and who which sector of
the economy to lend to credit allocation
Credit Control the bank of Japan gave
quarterly instructions to individual
banks on the value of loans and which
industrial sectors they should be
allocated
to all loans were broken down in sectors
and Subs sectors and large-scale
borrowers had to be listed by
name the bank of Japan could decide
which project should be encouraged and
which should be discouraged by dictating
to whom and for what banks could issue
loans this was the war economy system
adapted to the production of consumer
[Music]
goods the 95 million people of Japan now
enjoy a national income second only to
the United States and the more
prosperous nations of Western Europe
it's not a good system for capitalists
you know shareholders
but for the population it created a lot
of wealth very um even income and wealth
distribution very high growth and very
rapidly raised quality of life and
standability
in 1959 alone the economy expanded by
177% but a result of the war economy
system was that entire industrial
sectors would compete not for profit but
for market
share companies would fight until
bankruptcy to gain market
share this phenomenon was soon
recognized and called excess
competition the solution was the
creation of explicit or implicit
cartels in the banking sector window
guidance acted as the cartel control
mechanism because the bank of Japan
could dictate the number and value of
loans that Banks
issued as a result Bank rankings never
changed during the postwar era except
after
mergers according to one Banker if it
were not for window guidance we would
compete until
harakiri
the US current account deficit surges to
its highest level in 9 years the size of
the increase took many economists by
surprise while cartels controlled
competition within
Japan there were no such limits when it
came to International
markets Japanese corporations soon
became dominant in many markets in the
world in America formal Congressional
hearings were held under the title
Japanese productivity lessons for
America leading economic theories
indicate that only free markets can lead
to
success but Japan Rose within decades to
become the second largest economy in the
world without relying only on the
Invisible Hand of free
markets Japan's post-war economy was a
fully mobilized War economy with
production shifted from weapons to
consumer
[Music]
goods
since the bank of Japan presented itself
as a champion of free markets window
guidance was an
embarrassment official Publications
either failed to mention it or
downplayed its role by calling the
credit controls
voluntary whenever the Ministry of
Finance would inquire about the bank of
Japan's credit creation and allocation
policy Bank of Japan's staff would
engage in complex discussions full of
technical jargon to make the process
appear impenetrable to
non-experts in November 196 65 the first
batch of Japanese government bonds came
onto the
market from now on when politicians
wanted to spend more they would no
longer put pressure on the bank of
Japan but instead exert it on the
Ministry of
Finance so the ministry would ultimately
preside over an ever increasing national
debt
Mountain
[Music]
the 1980s was an era of financial
deregulation in industrialized world
world most industrialized countries
lifted their restrictions on the
movement of
capital in Japan Tadashi Sasaki a former
governor of the bank of Japan called for
a 5-year plan for the transformation and
liberalization of the Japanese
economy then in
1986 The Advisory Group on economic
restructuring headed by the former bank
of Japan Governor huo
maawa proposed a 10-year economic reform
plan designed to make the living
standards of Japanese more comparable to
those enjoyed in the
[Music]
west The Proposal stated that the time
has now come for Japan to make a
historical
transformation in its traditional
policies on economic IC management and
the nation's
lifestyle there can be no further
development for
Japan without this
transformation the report read like a
wish list by us trade
negotiators it started with calls for
administrative reform and the abolition
of Bureau ratic
Powers the goal was the transformation
of the entire body politic the abolition
of the war economy system and the
introduction of a US style free market
economy those members of The Advisory
Group who uttered dissent were relieved
of their
duties reports in the Press were highly
critical Observers recognized the
radical nature of the
plan it seemed far too
ambitious it was calling for a wholesale
revolution of all parts of the Japanese
economic political and social
system although the report was clear
about what was
wanted it was embarrassingly silent
about how these goals would be
achieved the only clue hidden in the
report was in the implementation of
these
recommendations fiscal and monetary
policy have a significant part to
[Music]
play the bank of Japan has always been
on the record arguing that this typical
Japanese system that we're so familiar
with um should be scrapped it just
should be entirely scrapped and US star
capitalism should be introduced now
whether you agree with that or not is an
entirely separate question but the bank
of Japan certainly thinks it should be
scrapped and U now the next question is
how do you do that well the Ministry of
Finance has been legally in control for
most of the postwar era we've got
entrenched bureaucratic structures uh
politicians and all these cartels and so
on that was the old system well history
teaches the system changes only
fundamentally if there's a
crisis the commission proposed that
monetary policy should be used to
promote a historic
crisis sufficiently large to overcome
the vested interests of the Ministry of
Finance politicians and corporate
Japan every system has groups that
benefit from it and hence have no desire
to change
it there is probably no country in the
world that has changed its economic
social and political system in a
significant way without a
crisis it is the crisis that convinces
citizens and interest groups of the Need
For Change well then how can you achieve
this um well you need a crisis and the
best way to create it is to have a
bubble cuz that's how nobody stops
[Music]
you
the bank of Japan began to significantly
increase window guidance loan
quotas average yearly loan growth quotas
were close to 15% in the late
1980s one city Banker would later remark
during the bubble we wanted a certain
amount of loan increases but the bank of
Japan wanted us to use
[Music]
more
the credit boom caused not only a boom
in real estate but also in the stock
market between 1985 and
1989 stocks Rose
240% and land prices 245
per. by the end of the80s the value of
the garden surrounding the Imperial
Palace in central Tokyo was worth as
much as the entire State of
California
[Music]
although Japan is only 126th the size of
the United States its land was valued at
four times that of the United
States the market value of a single one
of Tokyo's 23 districts the central
chioda Ward exceeded the value of the
whole of Canada
economists who are trained to believe in
Market outcomes tried to justify the
high land prices some thought land
scarcity was the
[Music]
reason shiny new corporate headquarters
Rose in Tokyo's poshh business
districts the labor market boomed so
much that there was a genuine fear of a
serious labor
shortage companies started to invite
final year University students on
expensive trips to Holiday
resorts to entice them to sign
up the politicians loved it the ministry
Finance loved it we had a boom tax
revenues going up the companies loved it
everything was wonderful in the bubble
[Music]
era
with asset and stock prices rising
inexorably even traditional
manufacturers could not resist the
temptation to try their hand at playing
the
markets soon they expanded their finance
and treasury divisions to handle the
speculation themselves
these company hedge funds known as zitec
used borrowed money to engage in
property and share
speculation the frenzy reached such
proportions that many leading
manufacturers such as the car maker
Nissan made more money through
speculative Investments than through
manufacturing
cars literally thousands of Articles
were written on the new Japanese Amic
economy a common explanation by
economists was that high and Rising
productivity explained the impressive
performance of Japan's
economy books on Japanese management
techniques became International bests
sellers Western businessmen read 17th
century tracks on Samurai
strategies
[Music]
in reality Japan's Stella performance in
the 1980s had little to do with
management
techniques instead of being used to
limit and direct credit window guidance
was used to create a giant
bubble I conducted a research actually
interviewing Bank of Japan officers and
bankers both sides on you know on tape
the result was the bank of Japan did um
continue its informal guidance in fact
it was the bank of Japan that forced the
banks to increase their lending so
much the bank of Japan knew that the
only way for banks to fulfill their loan
quotas was for them to expand
nonproductive Lending
ending in the words of one Banker if
there is no demand for credit from
lowrisk borrowers and we want to use up
the quota the risk gets
worse another Banker is quoted as saying
that a side effect of the window
guidance rule of loan
increases was that the banks increased
lending even when there was no loan
demand
like all bubbles the Japanese bubble was
simply fueled by the rapid creation of
new money by the banking
system between 1986 and 1989 toshihiko
fukui was the head of the banking
department at the bank of
Japan this was the department that was
responsible for the wind window guidance
quotas when fukui was asked by a
journalist borrowing is expanding fast
don't you have any intention of closing
the tap on bank loans he
replied because the consistent policy of
monetary easing continues quantity
control of bank loans would imply a
self-contradiction therefore we do not
intend to implement quantitative
tightening
with structural adjustment of the
economy going on for quite a long period
the international imbalances are being
addressed the monetary policy supports
this thus we have the responsibility to
continue the monetary easing policy as
long as
possible therefore it is natural for
bank loans to
expand why were the banks lending so so
much well they were lending so much
because they were forced to do so by the
orders of the bank of
Japan normally Banks choose clients from
among a large number of loan applicants
turning down a significant
percentage but from 1987 onwards the
tables had
turned it was the bank ERS who were
aggressively pursuing potential
customers anecdotes abound about how the
banks were soliciting loans at bargain
interest
rates pursuing clients like Street
pedlers
Bankers made increasingly exaggerated
assessments of land value so that the
actual ratio of land value to loan often
jumped to 300% or
more to the public this was a strange
phenomenon people soon dubbed it excess
money only economists analysts and those
working in the financial markets or for
Real Estate firms knew
better they dismissed such simplistic
analysis land prices were going up due
to far more complicated reasons than
just excess money they claimed Ordinary
People simply did not understand the
intricacies of Advanced Financial
technology
when a country creates too much money
some of that money spills out abroad in
the form of
investments in the
1980s Japanese Capital flows multiplied
from a net inflow of more than $2
billion in
1980 to an outflow of $132 billion in
1986 assets including art objects and
other valuables all over the world
became targets for Japanese
buyers there were high-profile purchases
such as the Rockefeller Center Columbia
Pictures and Pebble Beach Golf
Course Japanese money bought a St
staggering 75% of all United States
Treasury bonds auctioned off in
1986 but it is not easy for a country to
just print money and then go on a
shopping spree around the
world Japan was able to do this because
the markets did not devalue its
currency the value of individual
currencies is set by currency dealers
if the traditional indicators that the
currency dealers watch do not pick up
the excess money Creation in the country
concerned then creating large amounts of
money and trying to exchange it for
foreign currency can
work Japan had pulled off the same trick
that the United States had used in the
1950s and
1960s when you US Banks excessively
created
dollars Corporate America used this hot
money to buy up European
corporations while the United States had
the cover of the dollar gold
standard Japan's cover was a significant
Trade
Surplus
an early warning indicator of the
buildup of systemic risk in the banking
system is a ratio of loans for non- GDP
based transactions to Total
loans this ratio increases significantly
in most countries that are subsequently
struck by a banking
crisis
it was this same process that fueled the
mortgage lending and house price booms
in the United States and the United
Kingdom in the 1980s and the
2000s the same process also created the
golden
20s in the 1920s United States Banks
lent with stocks as
collateral the principle Remains the
Same as each bank took the stock price
as a given
it created new
money with more money in the stock
market stock prices had to
rise each Bank thought it was safe
accepting a certain percentage of the
value of the stock as
collateral but the actions of all banks
together drove up the overall
Market in Japan total private sector
land wealth Rose from4 .2 trillion yen
in
1969 to 2,000 trillion yen in
1989 at his first press conference was
the 26th governor of the bank of Japan
in
1989 yasushi mieno said that since the
previous policy of monetary easing had
caused the land price rise problems real
estate related lending would now be
restricted
he looked around looked at the bubble
asset price is rising you know the the
gap between rich and poor is getting
bigger let's stop it his name was Mr Moo
and he was a hero in the Press because
he fought against this silly monetary
policy well the fact was he was Deputy
Governor during the bubble era and he
was in charge of creating the
bubble
[Music]
all of a sudden land and asset prices
stopped
rising in 1990 alone the stock market
dropped by 32%
[Music]
then in July 1991 window guidance was
abolished this took the window guidance
officers at the bank of Japan themselves
by
surprise Bankers were left almost
helpless they complained that they did
not know how to make their lending plans
anymore in the past when a certain
Branch had said they would like to lend
more
they would respond that the window
guidance quota had been used
up now they couldn't do that
[Music]
anymore as Banks began to realize that
the majority of the 99 trillion yen in
bubble loans were likely to turn
sour they became so fearful that they
not only stopped lending to speculators
but also restricted loans to everyone
else well a bleak Christmas ahead for
Japan the stock market on Monday sinking
to its lowest close in over 2 years last
week's collapse of one of Japan's
biggest food Traders was the ninth time
this year that a listed company went
under more than 5 million Japanese lost
their jobs and did not find employment
elsewhere suicide became the leading C
cause of death for men between the ages
of 20 and
[Music]
44 between 1990 and
212,000 companies went
bankrupt in the same period the stock
market dropped by
[Music]
80% land prices in the major cities fell
by up to
84% some economists seemed relieved the
downturn was evidence that Japan's
economic system was not so successful
after
all meanwhile the governor of the bank
of Japan yasushi Mio said that thanks to
this recession everyone is becoming
conscious of the need to implement
economic
[Music]
transformation the Ministry of Finance
believing that interest rates were the
main policy tool put pressure on the
bank of Japan to lower interest
rates until the official rate R reached
0.1% most economists predicted an
economic
[Music]
recovery but despite frequent assertions
in the financial press and by central
banks that lower interest rates will
stimulate growth and higher interest
rates will slow growth there is no
empirical evidence for this
relationship
Japanese and American businessmen are
meeting here with a plea from Japan's
companies for a lower Yen only 6% of
Japanese exporters can make profits with
the dollar at less than 100 yen on
average they need the American currency
to rise above 117 yen to break
[Music]
even the Ministry of Finance
asked the bank of Japan to sell large
amounts of Yen and buy US
dollars so that the exchange rate of the
Yen would fall and exports would pick
up we all know that two of them the
Ministry of Finance moth in Japan and
the bank of Japan they just don't get
along well and what has been happening
also again this month is that the bank
of Japan has been sterilizing its own
intervention well to be precise
intervention ordered by the Ministry of
Finance the Ministry of Finance tells
the bank of Japan to go out and buy well
we had a figure roughly 20 billion worth
of us treasuries but the bank of Japan
is sterilizing this which means it is
basically taking the money from the
economy to fund this purchase most
researchers agree sterilized Forex
intervention doesn't work the boj is
again sterilizing that's why it doesn't
work that's why the Yen has remained
strong
[Music]
a central bank can withdraw money from
the economy by selling its
assets just as it can inject money into
the economy by buying
[Music]
assets when central banks buy and sell
assets they increase or decrease the
amount of money circulating in the
[Music]
economy officials at the bank of Japan
ignored this
and instead claimed that this structural
transformation or reform May produce
deflationary forces in the short run but
will generate a much more efficient
economy after a
while independent observers suggested
that domestic demand had to be boosted
by government
spending and then loan demand would also
rise for a decade the government
followed their advice boosting
government debt to Historic
levels between 1992 and 2002 10
stimulation packages worth 146 trillion
yen were
issued Mr Richard verer is Chief
Economist at Jardine Fleming Securities
in Tokyo he joins us now to share his
views on where the Japanese economy is
heading Mr verer good evening thank you
for joining us the government was
spending with a right hand putting money
into the economy but the fundraising was
done through the bond market and
therefore it took the same money out of
the economy with a left hand there was
no increase in total purchasing power
that's why the government spending
couldn't have an
impact by
2011 Japan's government debt would reach
230% of GDP the highest in the
world
the Ministry of Finance was running out
of
options observers began to blame the
ministry for the recession and started
to listen to the voices that argued that
the recession was due to Japan's
economic
system but how difficult would it have
been to solve the problems of bad debt
in the banking sector and
deflation it turns out that this would
not have been so difficult after all
Financial system always looks like Catch
22 there's no loan growth so there's no
economic growth so there's no loan
growth so there's no economic growth
well there is one thing that can break
through that this uh circular argument
that's the Central Bank the job of the
Central Bank in the situation is to
print
money what we need now is more radical
measures and there are some painful ones
but there also painless ones the Central
Bank could for example just buy all bad
debts at face value Japan would have the
strongest banks in the
world to bail out the banking sector a
central bank can buy up the bank's bad
financial assets with newly created
money giving them face value for assets
which are often worth significantly
less this is what the bank of Japan did
after the war
alternatively money could be transferred
to the banks by helping them make
sizable
profits one way this can be achieved is
for the central bank to corner a market
in effect creating a mini bubble in a
certain Market in which banks invest
heavily providing large profits for
them this turns out to be a relatively
common technique by central banks to
help their banking systems
other proposals include measures to
introduce zero risk borrowers to Banks
or introducing accounting changes that
help their balance
[Music]
sheets in Japan the authorities and the
bank of Japan argued as did the Western
Powers almost two decades later that the
taxpayer should foot the
bill in March uh last year and you may
remember the uh government injected a
large amount of money into some 15 major
Japanese financial institutions and we
were one of them yeah that helped us uh
uh write off bad debts and also to beef
up a capital base so that we wouldn't be
prepare to
lend tax money has been used to
recapitalize
Banks however there is no evidence that
taxpayers have been responsible for the
bank's problems therefore such policies
have likely created a moral
hazard the money supply is determined by
the net increase in money creation by
Banks and the central
bank if moral Hazard dictates that the
banking sector should not be bailed out
deflation and recession can still be
avoided by the central
bank to do this the central bank can
increase the money
supply a central bank can increase the
amount of money in an economy at any
time without
limit by simply buying assets from the
private sector and paying with newly
created
credit the bank of Japan could for
instance have bought real estate and
converted it into public
parks and there is an opportunity here
to solve three problems in one stroke
the economy needs money creation the
banks need to get rid of their bad debt
and the real estate sector need some
transactions well what he can do is just
have the Central Bank print money um buy
the land from the banks turn it into
parks and actually you solve another
problem quality of life in Japan
even if the bank of Japan had later sold
these parks at a fraction of the cost it
would still have made money because it
costs a central bank nothing to create
the money in the first
place another option for injecting money
into the economy is quantitative
easing despite having all these options
available the bank of Japan at every
stage refused to implement policy
that would have resolved the
crisis when I was at the bank of Japan
9293 as a visiting
researcher I was convinced that this
recession was going to get really bad so
any Bank of Japan guy who I could get to
talk to me I would ask
well why aren't you printing more money
I noticed they were not printing enough
money and I met one guy who was quite
open about that he said Richard yeah
sure we could have pred more money we
could have created a recovery but then
nothing would have changed
Japan's economic structure would not
have
changed now that time I still wasn't
ready to believe that the bank of Japan
was seriously prolonging the recession
on purpose in order to get structural
changes that just seemed bit too
wild Finance Minister maso Judo shiokawa
has turned to the bank of Japan asking
it to help stop deflation or fight
deflation at least the bank of Japan
consistently defied calls by the
government Finance Minister and prime
minister to create more money to
stimulate the economy and end the long
recession at times the bank of Japan
even actively reduced the amount of
money circulating in the economy which
worsened the
[Music]
recession the bank of Japan's arguments
always came to the same
conclusion namely that the blame lay
with Japan's economic
structure Central Bank staff even argued
that significant monetary easing could
cause
harm by inducing a further delay in the
progress of structural
adjustment the early post-war Japanese
leaders knew that they were running a
war economy but they chose not to talk
for political Reas
reasons the Cold War propaganda message
was that postwar Japan had adopted a US
style political and economic
system unwilling to tell the truth the
early post-war leaders took their
intimate knowledge about the origins of
Japan's Miracle economy with them to
their
grave a generation of bureaucrats and
politicians reigned in the 1980s and
1990s who did not understand the true
character and purpose of their own
country's
economy a whole generation of Japan's
economists had been sent to the United
States to receive phds and mbas in US
style
economics since neoclassical economics
assumes that there is only one type of
economic system namely unmitigated free
markets where shareholders and Central
Bankers rule
Supreme many Japanese economists quickly
came to regurgitate the arguments of us
economists the US and Japan closed two
days of insurance talks on Tuesday
primary sector
deregulation is needed to
overcome the entrenched
interests of large insurance companies
life and
non-life and the Ministry of Finance
bureaucracy they need to reach an
agreement before December the 15th after
that date the US is threatened to impose
trade sanctions will key move analysts
are expecting the securitization of real
estate well will the package be enough
for more we are talking to Richard ver
to have uh meaningful uh securitization
we need deregulation and that's already
the answer to your question uh to get
deregulation you have to reduce the
power of the Ministry of Finance and uh
obviously the ministry was resisting
that in the
1980s persons who could introduce
themselves with a business card from the
renowned finance ministry elicited deep
and hushed exclamations of awe and
respect but by the mid 199 90s attitudes
had
changed there now seemed little doubt to
most observers that the Ministry of
Finance had caused the
recession frequent demonstrations were
held outside the ministry's doors by
citizens disgusted by the bureaucrats
actions in early
1998 Public prosecutors for the first
time raided the most powerful of Japan's
Ministries
both Banks and their Regulators were
heavily criticized for their
actions scandals highlighted some of the
informal links that existed between
Ministry of Finance officials and
bankers many Bank staff and even some
Ministry officials were arrested and
imprisoned and several committed
suicide as Central Banker masaki
shirakawa had
explained it is not easy to change the
institutional framework and promote
structural
reform since it necessarily involves the
vested interests of all the related
individual economic
agents while utaka Yamaguchi a Deputy
Governor of the bank of Japan had said
that the bank of Japan had faced the big
dilemma that monetary EAS would produce
the mitigation of immediate risks which
in turn would result in a delaying of
adopting ultimate
solutions from the mid 1990s onwards the
government began to dismantle much of
the power structure of the ministry of
Finance the bank of Japan on the other
hand saw its influence grow
significantly you have written just
recently there's no doubt in your mind
the Central Bank the bank of Japan will
be cut loose from the Ministry of
Finance and become pretty much
independent putting it on a footing with
other central banks briefly why are you
so sure basically the Ministry of
Finance which had been uh controlling um
legally at least the bank of Japan I
mean that's what the law says um has
lost all credibility the Ministry of
Finance is being blamed for the creation
of the bubble for the long recession and
uh for many other problems which had
which had we had recently in Japan
whereas the bank of Japan has been um
out of the spotlight of public criticism
and uh it's using that now to say well
the moth has been bad we we need
Independence now Richard thanks very
much I have been speaking to Richard
Werner Chief Economist at Jardine
Fleming Securities in Tokyo
[Music]
soon after his retirement from the
position of governor of the bank of
Japan in
1994 maneno embarked on a campaign
giving speeches to various associations
and interest
groups he lobbied for a change in the
Bank of Japan
law his line of argument was to subtly
suggest that the Ministry of Finance had
pushed the bank of Japan into the wrong
policies
to avoid such problems in the future the
bank of Japan needed to be given full
legal
Independence according to mieno making
central banks independent reflected the
human wisdom that had been nurtured by
history in
1998 monetary policy was put into the
hands of the newly Independent Bank of
Japan
so you're saying that politicians as
well as economists should be putting
more pressure towards the bank of Japan
in order to create more money but a lot
of critics are going to say that that is
intervening into the central bank's
Independence what do you make of that um
I think I think that's exactly right
that is intervening in the central
bank's Independence and that's exactly
what we
need
the numerous scandals that followed the
bursting of the bubble also brought down
the 1955 system of one party rule by the
liberal Democratic
party in the old system politicians did
not compete by proposing different
policies policy was made by the
bureaucrats and politicians merely
focused on appeasing local
constituencies with Public Works Pro
projects in October 1997 for the first
time in postwar history all policy
initiatives to stimulate the economy
originated from politicians not
bureaucrats then in early 2001 a new
type of politici was swept to
power Japanese government bonds staged
their biggest rally this month as
junichiro koizumi emerged as the hot
favorite to become the country's next
prime minister junichiro koizumi became
prime
minister in terms of his popularity and
his policies he is often compared to
Margaret Thatcher and Ronald
Reagan his message was simple no
recovery without structural
[Music]
reform at the Geneva Summit in July 2001
he said some say recovery comes first
without
reforms but if the economy recovers the
will to reform will
disappear therefore after the elections
I will continue with the plan of no
growth without structural
reform during 2001 the message of no
economic growth without structural
reform had been brought on an almost
daily basis on the nation's TV
[Music]
screens now everyone believes we need
structural changes we need to scrap
Japanese style capitalism to get a
recovery why it seems we tried all the
policies seems we've tried everything
nothing works so the system itself the
Japanese style economic system must be
to blame so we better get rid of
[Music]
it Japan was shifting its economic
system to a US style market
economy and that all o meant that the
center of the economy was being moved
from Banks to stock
markets to entice depositors to pull
their money out of Banks and into the
risky stock market reformers withdrew
the guarantee on all Bank deposits while
creating tax incentives for stock
Investments as us style shareholder
capitalism spread unemployment Rose
significantly income and wealth
disparities Rose as did suicides and
incidents of violent
crime then in 2002 the bank of Japan
strengthened its efforts to worsen bank
balance sheets and forc Banks to
foreclose on their
borrowers until then Haku yanagawa
Minister for financial services had
resisted the bank of Japan inspired
proposal to inject tax money into Banks
effectively nationalizing them taking
over their management and using this
power to call in loans from companies
thus triggering many bankruptcies of
large
firms Mr yanagawa was duly sacked by the
Prime Minister and replaced with heeso
takanaka takaka was a supporter of the
bank of Japan's plan to increase
foreclosures of
borrowers minister takak
was trying to implement a policy to
actually uh dramatically weaken the
balance sheets of the banks in order to
give him a free hand and allow him to
nationalize
them takanaka appointed a task force to
oversee the banking policies which
included two former bank of Japan
staff one of them Takeshi Kimura
immediately demanded that accounting
changes be implemented which would
worsen bank balance sheets and render
National ization
unavoidable takuru morinaga a well-known
Economist in Tokyo argued forcefully
that the bank of Japan inspired proposal
by takanaka would not have many
indigenous
beneficiaries but instead would mainly
benefit us vulture funds specializing in
the purchase of distressed
assets these vulture funds had faced the
difficulty that despite over over
200,000
bankruptcies few firms sufficiently
large for the vulture funds to be
interested were
bankrupted when kimura's and fukui
support for the bankruptcy plan was
voiced the former operated a private
company that advised on the
securitization of distressed
assets and the latter was an adviser of
the Wall Street investment firm Goldman
Sachs
one of the largest operators of vulture
funds in the
world Mr fuku also his mentor Mr Moo and
and his mentor Mr M Cara and you you've
guessed it these are some of the princes
of the Yen that the book is all about
they have said on the record in the 80s
and also throughout the '90s what is the
goal of monery policy it is to change
the economic structure now how do you do
that well you need a crisis and that's
really what they've done they the crisis
to change the economic just have to cut
you off thank you so much and we
apologize
the department responsible for the
window guidance quotas at the bank of
Japan was called the banking department
and who was in charge of this the man at
the head of this banking Department
inside the bank of Japan during the
bubble from 86 to 89 was Toshi fukui Mr
fukui the current governor of the bank
of Japan he's the man who created the
bubble when fukui had become governor of
the bank of Japan he would say while
destroying the high growth model I am
building a model that suits the new
era they have succeeded on all counts um
if you look at the list of their of
their goals and you know it was more
than a wish list was more or less a plan
that they mapped out uh they wanted to
achieve they've reached all those goals
destroy the Ministry of Finance uh break
it up get an independent Financial
supervisory agency reach Independence
for the bank of Japan Itself by changing
the bank of Japan
law um and uh engineer deep structural
changes in the economy um by shifting
from manufacturing to Services opening
up deregulating Liber liberalizing
privatizing the whole loot in the 1920s
Japan's economy in many ways resembled
today's US
economy with Fierce competition
aggressive hiring and firing takeover
battles between large corporations
few bureaucratic controls strong
shareholders that demanded High
dividends and corporate funding from the
markets not
Banks yet throughout the postwar era
Japan's economy had been the opposite
highly regulated with cartels limiting
competition Bank financing and cross
shareholdings reducing shareholder power
no takeovers and a frozen labor market
with lifetime employment and seniority
pay
it was claimed that to end the recession
and improve performance Japan must shift
from welfare capitalism back to
shareholder
capitalism yet it remains unclear why a
country that had run a consistent and
significant balance of trade
surplus would need to change its
economic system to become more
competitive
Japan was not the only high- performance
economy in Asia that in the 1990s found
itself in the deepest recession since
the Great
Depression in
1997 the currencies of the Southeast
Asian tiger economies could not maintain
a fixed exchange rate with the US dollar
they collapsed by between 60 and 80%
within a
year the causes for this crash went as
far back as
1993 in that year the Asian tiger
economies South Korea Thailand and
Indonesia implemented a policy of
aggressive deregulation of the capital
account and the establish lishment of
international banking facilities which
enabled the corporate and banking
sectors to borrow liberally from
abroad the first time in the post-war
era that borrowers could do
so in reality there was no need for the
Asian tiger economies to borrow money
from
abroad all the money necessary for
domestic invest
could be created at
home indeed the pressure to liberalize
Capital flows came from
outside since the early 1990s the IMF
the World Trade Organization and the US
Treasury had been lobbying these
countries to allow domestic firms to
borrow from
abroad they argued that neoclassical
economics had proven that free markets
and free Capital movement increased
economic
growth once the capital accounts had
been deregulated the central banks set
about creating irresistible incentives
for domestic firms to borrow from
abroad by making it more expensive to
borrow in their own domestic currencies
than it was to borrow in US
Dollars domestic local interest rates
were high were high higher than the US
dollar interest rate okay and the
exchange rate uh was uh virtually fixed
it was the government and the central
bank that said we will maintain the
exchange rate that's right that's right
central banks of uh of Thailand and
other East Asian countries resisted uh
exchange rate
adjustment uh and they they uh tried to
send the signal that they would protect
the change
rate the central banks emphasized in
their public statements that they would
maintain fixed exchange rates with the
US
dollar so that borrowers did not have to
worry about paying back more in their
domestic currencies than they had
originally
borrowed when I went to Thailand I was
actually on an ADB Mission as an outside
consultant I went straight to the bank
of Thailand and asked them were there
any informal credit uh guidance schemes
and they were surprised that I asked
this question because of my study of
Japan I thought perhaps there's
something similar and they told me it
was a young staff who perhaps wasn't
aware of the politics involved he said
yeah yeah we have this credit planning
scheme Banks were ordered to increase
lending but they were faced with less
loan demand from the productive sectors
of the
economy because these firms had been
given incentives to borrow from abroad
instead they therefore had to resort to
increasing their lending to higher risk
borrowers Imports began to shrink
because the central banks had agreed to
Peg their currencies to the US
dollar the economies became less
competitive but their current account
balance was made maintained due to the
foreign issued
loans which count as exports in the
balance of payment
statistics when speculators began to
sell the Thai Bart the Korean one and
the Indonesian rupe the respective
central banks responded with futile
attempts to maintain the peg until they
had squandered virtually all of their
foreign exchange Reserves
this gave foreign lenders ample
opportunity to withdraw their money at
the overvalued exchange
rates the central banks knew that if the
countries ran out of Foreign Exchange
reserves they would have to call in the
IMF to avoid
default and once the IMF came in the
central banks knew what this
washington-based institution would
demand for its demands in such cases had
been the same for the previous three
decades the central banks would be made
independent on the 16th of July the Thai
Finance Minister took a plane to Tokyo
to ask Japan for a
bailout at the time Japan had $213
billion US in foreign exchange
reserves more than the total resources
of the
IMF they were willing to help but
Washington stopped Japan's
initiative any solution to the emerging
Asian crisis had to come from Washington
via the
IMF after two months of speculative
attacks the Thai government floated the
bot
well the international monetary fund to
date has promised almost $20 billion to
the embattled economies of Thailand
Indonesia and South Korea immediately
after arrival in the crisis stricken
countries the IMF teams set up offices
inside the central
banks from where they dictated what
amounted to terms of
surrender the IMF demanded a string of
policies including curbs on Central Bank
and bank credit
creation major legal changes and sharp
rises in interest
rates as interest rates Rose high-risk
borrowers began to default on their
loans burdened with large amounts of bad
debts the banking systems of Thailand
Korea and Indonesia were virtually
bankrupt even otherwise healthy firms
started to suffer from the widening
credit
crunch corporate bankruptcies soared
unemployment Rose to the highest level
since the
1930s the role of the fund in coming to
the rescue of alien Nations has been
fiercely debated some have even accused
the IMF of actually making Asia's
economic crisis worse worse even if they
have to subvert our economy they will do
so just to prove that they are right the
MF has not been very
helpful the IMF knew well what the
consequences of its policies would
be in the Korean case they even had
detailed but undisclosed studies
prepared that had calculated just how
many Korean companies would go bankrupt
if interest rates were to rise by 5
percentage points
the imf's first agreement with Korea
demanded a rise of exactly 5 percentage
points in interest
rates the IMF policies um are clearly
not aimed at creating economic
recoveries in the Asian countries uh
they pursue quite a different agenda and
that is to change the economic social
and political systems in those countries
in fact the IMF deals prevent um the
countries concerned like Korea Thailand
um to reflate interesting you're saying
it's making the crisis worse and you're
suggesting that the IMF has a hidden
agenda well I mean it's not very hidden
this agenda because the IMF quite
clearly demands uh um that the Asian
countries concern have to change the
laws uh so that uh foreign interests can
buy anything from Banks to land um and
in fact the banking systems um can only
be recapitalized according to the IMF
deals uh by using foreign money which is
not necessary at all because as long as
these countries have central banks um
they could just print money and
recapitalize the banking systems you
don't need foreign money for that um so
the agenda is clearly to crack open Asia
um for foreign
interests the IMF demanded that troubled
Banks would not be bailed out but
instead closed down and sold off cheaply
as distressed
assets often to large US investment
Banks one positive coming out of
Thailand is that they'll be auctioning
off uh some major assets from uh 56
finance companies in your view should
um some of the owners from the 56
finance companies be allowed to buy back
their
Assets in most cases the IMF dictated
letters of intent explicitly stated that
the banks had to be sold to foreign
investors
and let me emphasize in that respect
that these reform programs are the key
the absolute key to restoring Financial
stability for the first time ever South
Korea closed five banks in a major step
toward meeting its IMF mandate the
number of commercial Banks has has
declined has been reduced as a result of
uh uh closure mergers and uh
Acquisitions and the foreign strategic
investors are now in uh which uh which
is a remarkable
change in Asia government organized
bailouts to keep aien financial
institutions alive were not
allowed but when a similar crisis struck
back home in America a year
later the very same institutions reacted
differently
the Connecticut based hedge fund
long-term Capital Management which
accepted as clients only High net worth
individual investors and
institutions had leveraged its5 billion
in client Capital by more than 25
times borrowing more than100 billion us
from the world's
Banks
when its losses threatened to undermine
the banks that had lent to it with the
possibility of a systemic banking crisis
that would endanger the US Financial
system and economy the Federal Reserve
organized a cartel likee bailout by
leaning on Wall Street and International
Banks to contribute
funds so that it could avoid
default yeah I mean you're right the the
the views from Washington and New York
seemed certainly quite flexible because
soon after they told all the Asian
countries no bailouts for financial
institutions um when then long-term
Capital Management a hedge fund in New
York almost went bust suddenly a bailout
was organized just contradicting what
they said to the Asian countries but
they said that there are no public money
used for ltcm but the meeting was held
famously inside the Federal Reserve
right why would the United States make
demands on foreign nations in the name
of the free
market when it has no intention of
enforcing the same rules within its own
borders the examples of the Japanese and
Asian crisis illustrate how crisis can
be engineered to facilitate the
redistribution of economic ownership and
to implement legal structural and
political
change today similar events are at work
in the Euro Zone
area countries within the euro currency
block have forfeited their right to a
national currency and handed this power
to the European Central
Bank with me here in the studio is
Richard verer he's the professor at
Southampton university Richard wasen
advised to the bank of Japan and the
Ministry of Finance at the end of the
the bubble era in the 1990s what your
advice the BCB they meet tomorrow what
would you be what would you be telling
them um well again I mean they they have
to focus on the quantity of credit
creation more than interest rates the
ECB has a lot um to um to learn from its
past mistakes because basically I think
it didn't really watch carefully enough
credit creation where in Spain um
Ireland uh we had a massive credit
expansion under the watch of the ECB MH
he didn't look at that interest rates of
course are the same in the Euro Zone but
the the quantity of credit site was very
different there's one interest rate for
the whole Euro area but in 2002 the ECB
told the bundesbank to reduce its credit
creation by the biggest amount in its
history and told the Irish Central Bank
to to print as much money as if there's
no tomorrow what do you expect is going
to happen same interest rate is same
growth no recession in Germany boom in
Ireland which one tells you that which
variable credit
creation from 2004 under the ecb's watch
Bank credit growth in Ireland Greece
Portugal and Spain increased by over 20%
per anom and property prices
skyrocketed when Bank credit fell
property prices collapsed developers
went bankrupt and the banking systems of
Ireland Portugal Spain and Greece became
insolvent the ECB could have prevented
these bubbles just as it could have
ended the ensuing Banking and economic
crisis but it refused to do so until
major political concessions had been
made such as the transfer of fiscal and
budgeting powers from each sovereign
state to the European
Union in both Spain and Greece youth
unemployment has been pushed up to 50%
forcing many youths to seek employment
abroad Greek doctors for whose education
Greek taxpayers have paid now work in
Germany the deliberations of the ecb's
decision-making bodies are
secret the mere attempt at influencing
the
ECB for instance through democratic
debate and discussion is forbidden
according to the mastri
treaty the ECB is an international
organization that is above and outside
the laws and jurisdictions of any
individual
Nation its senior staff carry diplomatic
passports and the files and documents
inside the European Central Bank cannot
be searched or impounded by any police
force or public
prosecutor the ECB is well known among
economists as one of the world's most
powerful and least transparent central
banks yet its former president
jeanclaude trishe dealt with this
problem by merely asserting that there
was no
problem the ECB is one of the most
transparent central banks in the world
and has helped Define the
state-ofthe-art of Central Banking in
this domain he
claimed the gentleman over there yes
please come on your name is Richard van
I'm an economist my question is for Miss
who's also been for years member of the
governing Council of the ECB the
question is where in the mastr treaty or
ECB statutes does it say that is the job
of the ECB to back structural reform or
any other political agenda I said very
very clearly and we have all said very
very clearly that we had no
responsibility in this domain we have a
voice and we say in this domain and in
some others what we think think and
perhaps if we can help in explaining
from our side to the general people that
they would be better off perhaps it
would help Europe embarking in this
implementation of structural reforms
which is so important and there is a
consensus on that the diagnosis again is
a a very very very large consensus on on
this uh on this
point
the European commission an unelected
group whose aim is to build the United
States of Europe with all the trappings
of a unified
state has an interest in weakening
individual governments and the influence
of the democratic parliaments of
Europe it turns out that the evidence
for Central Bank Independence that was
relied upon in the mastri treaty derived
from a single study that was
commissioned by none other than the
European commission
itself published in 1992 under the name
one market one money the study purported
to demonstrate that Central Bank
Independence led to low
inflation James forer an Oxford academic
has since demonstrated that this study
was manipulated to obtain the desired
result the store story being told by the
central banks just does not add up uh
and there is evidence that central banks
work differently from uh what they would
like us believe um as to how they
work the world over central banks hold
significant yet little understood
Powers often independent unaccountable
and obscure central banks operate in the
shadows yet their actions affect us all
central banks um in almost all countries
worldwide and the IMF has helped a lot
in in achieving this they' become
totally independent and in practice not
accountable to any Democratic
institution um and accountability to
Parliament is usually minor and in
practice
meaningless whether it is the Bank of
Japan the Federal Reserve the bank of
England or the European Central Bank
examples of Central Bank deception
abound
in the United States in the 1920s Banks
were encouraged to create money and give
it to
speculators the resulting depression
persuaded the freedom-loving Americans
that a decentralized federal system
without strong National controls could
not
[Music]
work in the
1990s the Japanese were persuaded that
their economic system which had brought
cons considerable prosperity and
equality needed to be changed into a
so-called free market
system and while Japan's transformation
was not yet
complete the central Bankers struck
again with an IMF Le raid on the Asian
tiger
economies the present European debt
crisis is yet another example of Central
Bank deception
to create a public consensus for the
need for structural
reform by purposefully creating a
recession and then needlessly prolonging
it must constitute an abuse of
power do citizens really want to be
manipulated in such a costly and
dishonest
manner any action or you might lost the
part of your
[Music]
body
is
[Music]
for